[Music]
ohayo gozaimasu good morning it is now
the third time that I have the privilege
to welcome you all to noble price dialog
here in Tokyo can we feed 10 billion
people I felt that this dialogue was
very inclusive and diverse and this can
be a model for other international
conference the future of food is really
going to depend on what we do with
agriculture in Africa this was the first
dialogue I took part in and it was a
very interesting experience because I
came together with a lot of very diverse
people it seems to be an honest attempt
to bring science closer to a broader
public and the heels of the last
conversation I think this is a really
appropriate topic because if we're
talking about nutrition I think we
actually need to think about how foods
nourish the bacteria in our intestine
this provides like a very good platform
for me to expose my very nascent
thinking to the big mindsets of the
Nobel Prize winners so I'm here to take
inspiration I found it very very
entertaining especially the sort of the
evolution of the faithful yes we can
introduce this there all countries of
food to introduce your culture into
space they can introduce this Japanese
food onboard International Space Station
most important part is by eating this
whole country's food it makes the
astronauts psychology very well I'm very
interested about the Nobel Prize
discussion in general so yes this is my
second year attending here I was a
curious child from childhood I even
bought my hand
I tried to find a the distance from the
flow today to the ceiling which was very
important for me the age of five in
creativity it is to have the ability to
ask the right question but curiosity is
most important for science you have
better-funded
very interesting subject you want to
know you touched on a very important
point which I often worry about you know
I think finding a good problem for a
scientist or any kind of person is the
most difficult thing this is the second
time we we participate in a dialogue in
Tokyo it's an excellent opportunity to
bring some of the key I would say
stakeholders and partners within our
industry together and discuss important
topics about the future food it was
greater and very much concentrated
content wise so I learned quite a lot
today thanks to this dialogue so thank
you very much for inviting me to come
here thank you all of you for attending
it's been a real pleasure arigatou
gozaimasu
you
[Applause]